hi my name is dilicani and i will be
presenting the work on fairness and
stability in two-sided matchings
this is a joint walk with guy rodbloom
and galiona from the weizmann institute
human decision makers are increasingly
being replaced by algorithms for example
setting bail in the american legal
system selecting ads to show on websites
and more
these algorithms usually maximize some
utility function
however because they involve high stakes
for the participants it is also
important that they do not discriminate
specifically we focus on one-to-one
allocation problem where each individual
receives a single outcome we want to
find an allocation that is both fair and
useful
we use the setting of two-sided matching
as a running example let us consider the
location of doctors to hospitals for
residency
each hospital is matched to a single
doctor
our goal is to find the full matching
between two sets of the same size
doctors and hospitals
in which each doctor or hospital has an
ordinal preference over the other set
as an example consider these preferences
where the violent doctor prefers the
yellow hospital over the blue hospital
and the blue hospital over the white
hospital
similarly the yellow hospital prefers
the viral doctor over the blue doctor
and the blue doctor over the green
doctor
the goal is to find a matching that is
stable
which is defined by the absence of
blocking pairs
a blocking pair consists of a doctor and
hospital that prefer to be matched with
each other rather than with their
matched partner
as an example consider this matching
since the violet doctor refers the
yellow hospital over the blue hospital
and the yellow hospital refers the
violet doctor over the blue doctor this
matching is not stable
this is because the violent doctor and
the yellow hospital prefer to be matched
instead of participating in this
specific matching
this notion of stability was introduced
in the seminal work of garen chapli who
showed that the stable matching always
exists and can be found efficiently
our goal is to find a stable matching
that is also felt to the doctors
before formalizing what fairness even
means in this context
one issue is that the preferences of the
hospitals might not be fair to begin
with
a discriminatory hospital preference may
lead to an unfair matching
as an example if some prestigious
hospital prefers doctor from one ethnic
group other doctors from another ethnic
group without considering their merits
this may lead to an unfair matching
however if the preferences of the
hospitals are fair will this guarantee a
fair matching
we show that even if the preferences of
the hospitals are fair it is not clear
what it guarantees
our main question is are fairness and
stability compatible
another problem is that under our
environment for fairness which i will
define soon a deterministic matching
does not always exist
rather than a deterministic matching we
would like to find a probabilistic one
that is a distribution over matchings
our fairness and stability requirement
are a priori meaning over the
distribution
to begin we will consider a limited
setting where we assume that the
preferences of the hospitals are in a
restricted class of fair hospital
preferences
i will explain this assumption in more
detail shortly
based on this assumption we present two
results
the first result is that although we
assume that the hospital preferences are
fair
simply running the gain sharply
algorithm is not sufficient to guarantee
that the final allocation is actually
fair
however in our second result we present
an algorithm that does ensure both
fairness and stability under this
assumption
it is based on the structure of the gail
shapley algorithm
lastly we show that if the assumption is
even partially removed no gale sharply
style algorithm is able to achieve both
fairness and stability
we show this by defining a general
algorithms class and showing that any
algorithm in this class fails
in order to show our results i will
first define
what is a fair matching
what is our stability requirement in a
probabilistic setting
and
what are fair hospital preferences
for the fairness requirement we use we
assume a given similarity metric a
distance function this metric should be
unbiased and should only consider the
merit of the doctors the distances
between two doctors are between zero and
one and the metric is actually
epsodometric that is we allow two
different doctors to have the distance
of zero much of this work is focused on
photometrics
metrics in which distances are either
zero or one
meaning that every two doctors are
either the same or completely different
according to this definition the doctors
are divided into clusters where the
distance between doctor in each cluster
is zero while the distance between
doctor in different clusters is one
the definition of individual fairness
proposed by dwarket al takes merit into
account and says that similar doctors
should have similar outcomes
however
what if they have different preferences
for instance based on geographic
location
a pair of equally capable doctors could
prefer different hospitals and shouldn't
be forced to have the same outcome just
because of the fairness requirement
so
instead of individual fairness we use
preferences informed individual fairness
opif proposed by kim at all which is a
relaxation of individual fairness and
allows deviations from individual
fairness as long as they are aligned
with the doctor's preferences
i will present the fairness requirement
over the allocation peace under the
assumption that the similarity metric is
a photometric
that is the distances are either zero or
one
restricting our attention to this simple
setting simplifies the definitions but
the paper also studies the definitions
in more general settings
between clusters meaning doctors that
are in distance 1 for each other we have
no guarantee that is no fairness
requirement to enforce
in each clusters
doctors that are in distance zero from
each other will require angry freeness
which implies that each doctor prefers
its own allocation over the allocation
of any other doctor in its cluster
according to this doctor's preferences
the outcomes are compared using
stochastic domination
according to doctor's i preferences a
location piece stochastically dominates
a location q if for every k the
probability of being allocated to the
top k outcome according to dr i's
preference says in p is greater or equal
to that in q
for example the probability to be
assigned with the dr i's first choice in
p
is greater or equal than in q
similarly the probability of being
assigned to doctor i's first or second
choices in p
is greater or equal than in q and so on
hence to have a fair location each
doctor of the location should
stochastically dominate the location of
its spheres in the cluster
this concludes the definition of film
matching we are now prepared to define
verb references
for a protometric a natural definition
for fail preferences would be to require
indifference between doctors in the same
cluster
meaning that the hospital would not be
allowed to favor one doctor over the
other if the distance is zero
however we do allow hospitals to have
other preferences over the clusters
that it doctors want in distance one
from one another
another way to view the definition is a
probabilic or babylistic
of the preferences
we can represent the preferences of each
hospital using a distribution over
ordered preferences that is a
distribution over the order of a
complete list of the doctors
the order of the of the clusters is
chosen as referral and the order of the
doctor in each cluster is randomly
chosen from the uniform distribution
independently of the order of the
doctors in other clusters
this concludes the definition of fair
hospital preferences
next i will define stability in this
probabilistic setting
with the deterministic definition of
fair hospital preferences in mind were
able to naturally generalize the
definition of stability
according to the classical deterministic
definition emerging is unstable if there
is a blocking pair
that is an unmatched pair that prefers
each that prevails each other to their
match
in a probabilistic case we make the same
requirement over the matchings in the
support of the allocation
moreover we require strict reference
which means that the hospital cannot be
in a blocking pair with a doctor from
the same cluster as his matched partner
since it is not permitted to have strict
preferences between doctors in the same
cluster
to conclude we say an allocation is
unstable
if there exists a matching in the
support of the location that contains a
pair of a doctor and the hospital who
prefer each other over their partner in
the matching
and the doctor in the pair belongs to a
different cluster than the partner of
the hospital
we discussed the definition of stability
for unfair hospital preferences in the
paper
to conclude we use a metric based
fairness definition focus on
photometrics which are metrics for the
distances between between doctors are
either zero or one
we say an allocation is fair if it
satisfies envy freeness within each
cluster
that is every doctor prefers their own
allocation over the allocation of any
other doctor in the cluster we say the
preferences of a hospital are fair if it
has strict preference over the clusters
and is indifferent between doctors in
the same cluster
in addition we had a probabilistic
representation of the preferences where
the order of the doctors in the same
cluster was sampled uniformly at random
finally we defined stability as the
absence of blocking pairs in any
matching in the support of the location
with hospitals only allowed to be in a
blocking pair with doctors from
different clusters than their partner in
the matching
next i will present the first result
that under the assumption of a
photometric and fair hospital
preferences running the gail sharply
algorithm fails
our report approach builds upon gail and
chapli's two-sided stable matching
algorithm which i will present now
in this problem we match two sets of the
same size where each individual in each
set has an ordinal preference over the
individuals in the other set
in our example of doctors and hospitals
each doctor has preferences over the
hospital and vice versa
in the algorithm each set plays a
distinct role one set is the proposing
set
without loss of generality let's assume
that these are the doctors and the other
set is the accepting set we'll assume
that these are the hospitals
the algorithm works as follows
while the matching is not full an
unmatched individual is chosen
arbitrarily from the proposing set
in this example an unmatched doctor
currently no doctors are matched and so
the violent doctor is chosen arbitrarily
this violent doctor proposes to the most
preferred hospital the yellow hospital
since the yellow hospital is not matched
it accepts
now the only unmatched doctor is the
green one
so they have to propose the clean doctor
proposes to the most preferred hospital
the yellow hospital
the yellow hospital is already match
thus it has to decide
whether to stay matched to the violet
doctor and reject the green doctor
or reject the viral doctor and become
matched to the green doctor
as the yellow hospital refers the valid
doctor over the green doctor it will
reject the clean doctor
once the yellow hospital rejected the
green doctor this doctor removed the
yellow hospital from the list of
preference and would never propose to it
again
since the green doctor remains the only
unmatched doctor they are chosen again
now they will propose to the green
hospital which is unmatched and
therefore accepts
since there is no unmatched doctor the
algorithm is terminated with this
matching that is stable
next i will demonstrate how we use the
gail sharply algorithm in our
probabilistic set
a natural first step was to require fair
hospital preferences and then apply the
gail sharply algorithm to these
preferences
i said earlier that the hospital
preferences are fair if the hospitals
have strict ordinal preferences over the
clusters and are indifferent to doctors
in the same cluster
but how can we run the gameshop the
algorithm over such preferences
we can use the probabilistic
representation
and sample the preferences the
preferences are represented as a
distribution over ordinal preferences
with the same order of the clusters
where the order of the doctors in each
cluster is chosen uniformly at random
we then find the probabilistic
allocation by sampling this distribution
of each hospital preferences and running
the gail shapley algorithm over the
sample preferences
the formobilistic allocation is the
resulting random variable
hopefully the fairness of the
preferences will imply a fair allocation
but actually this approach fails
this result joins existing work that
shows failure of composition in fairness
that is all the participants acted
fairly and the mechanism seems unbiased
in that it doesn't explicitly favor some
of the doctors over the others
yet the outcome is still unfair
here i will show a counter example for
the case where the doctors are the
proposing set
in the paper we also provide an example
for the case where the hospitals are the
proposing set
in this example there are three doctors
and three hospitals the blue and violet
doctors are in the same cluster and the
green doctor is in a different cluster
these are the preferences as you can see
they aren't fair since the hospitals are
indifferent between the blue and violet
doctors
such that their order is chosen
uniformly
however if we sample these preferences
and run the gauge up the algorithm where
the doctors propose to the hospitals we
get the following allocation which is
unfair with respect to the blue doctor
to have a fair solution we require envy
freeness within each cluster in terms of
stochastic domination the blue doctor's
first choice is the yellow hospital and
they are never matched on the other hand
the violet doctor is mixed with the
yellow hospital with probability half
therefore the violet doctor has a higher
probability of getting the blue doctor's
first choice then the blue doctor
which means that the blue doctor's
outcome does not stochastically dominate
the violent doctoral outcome
and the matching is not fair
we get this surprising result although
we required symmetry in the hospital's
preferences the preferences of the blue
and violet doctors are not symmetrical
since the blue doctor prefers the green
hospital over the white hospital and the
valley doctor prefers the white hospital
over the green hospital
hence although the yellow hospital
accepted or rejected the blue and valid
doctor's proposal with the same
probability the different preferences
caused a difference in later rounds of
the execution causing the yellow
hospital to reject the blue doctor in
one case but not reject the viral doctor
in the other case
this raises the question of whether this
failure is specific for the gail shaklee
algorithm or inherent to the problem
i just showed that the naive approach of
sampling fell hospital's references and
running the gail sharply algorithm fails
next i will present the second result an
algorithm that guarantees both fairness
and stability
i will show an algorithm that
approximately solves this problem under
the assumption of a photometric and fair
hospital preferences the algorithm is
called firm propose and reject
unlike the previous approach of sampling
and running the gauge at the algorithm
hoping that the fair hospital
preferences will ensure a fair outcome
we force the hospitals to make the
decision simultaneously
for all the doctors in the cluster
we do that by allowing the participants
to propose and accept probability mass
at the end of the run we have an n over
n matrix which represents the
probability of each doctor to be matched
to each hospital
in order to extract the distribution
over matchings we use the bilkophon
human algorithm
our algorithm has two variants one with
the doctors proposing and one with the
hospitals proposing
similar to the girl sharply algorithm
here i will describe the version in
which the doctors propose
in the beginning of the execution every
doctor has three probability mass
initialized to one
on the right side you can see the
preferences of all the participants
the algorithm proceeds in rounds in each
round each doctor proposes all the three
probability mass they have to their
favorite hospital as long as this
hospital hasn't rejected them yet
this is similar to the proposals part in
the gail shapley algoeda
however in this algorithm all the
doctors propose simultaneously
in the first round the blue and violet
doctors propose to the yellow hospital
while the green doctor proposes to the
white hospital
these hospitals has no probability must
propose to them and they have to choose
which of it to accept
the mass proposed by each doctor
represents the probability to be matched
to that doctor in the final allocation
this is similar to the gail shapley
algorithm where individuals can choose
to accept a new match or stay with their
existing one
in this case the yellow hospital has
only probability mass 1 proposed to it
so it accepts all of it because it
prefers being matched to the green
doctor over not being matched at all
the yellow hospital has probability must
to propose to it and it must accept no
more than one
in a way that will not cause unfairness
this mass is proposed from two doctors
that belong to the same cluster
therefore it is clear what to do here
except half from each of them
they will keep going with the remaining
mass to the next hospitals in the
reference lists
that is basically our algorithm the
question is in general how a hospital
decides
when it is given a lot of different
units of mass
from different doctors in different
clusters
we use an algorithm we call the rising
tide algorithm to describe which
probability must to accept
our algorithm is called the rising
tide algorithm
because it reminds us of the law of
communicating vessels each doctor is
represented by a vessel with the same
width
and the capacity of the vessel is
determined by the probability mass this
doctor proposed to this hospital
in each cluster all the vessels are
connected in the beginning all the
hospital's mass is unallocated
we can think of the unallocated mass as
water
the hospital goes over all the clusters
starting with the most preferred cluster
and ending with the least preferred
cluster
and tries to pour water into the vessels
of the doctors in the cluster
if all the vessels are full it moves to
the next cluster with the remaining
water
until it has no more water to pour
or all the vessels are full
the water poured to each vessel
represents the accepted mass from that
doctor
that way it will first accept
probability mask from the clusters it
prefers more
also in each cluster all the doctors
will have the same amount of mass
accepted unless they proposed less than
others
in that case they reached their capacity
meaning the entire mass they proposed
was accepted
let's go back to the algorithm we had
two clusters of doctors
one with the blue and violet doctors and
one with the green doctor
at the beginning of the round each of
them proposed to their favorite hospital
the entire fremont which was one
now the hospitals have to decide what
must to accept
the must they accept from each doctor
represents the probability to be matched
to this doctor in the final allocation
the white hospital was proposed with
mass
of one
so there is no problem it will accept
all of it
the yellow hospital however was proposed
with total mass of two which is larger
than than one thus it must reject at
least one in order to accept a mass that
will represent a distribution
since the yellow hospital was proposed
which must form a single cluster it will
run the rising tide algorithm and accept
half from each doctor while rejecting
half from each doctor
as a result the rejected mass becomes
free
since the blue and violet doctor were
rejected by the hospital they will never
propose to this hospital again
next the blue and violet doctors propose
to the next hospitals in their
preference list the blue and white
hospitals the green doctor does not
propose since they have no free mass
because the green hospital was proposed
with less than probability must 1 it
will accept all of it
the white hospital has the most proposed
to it in the previous round from the
green doctor
and they must propose to it in this
round from the violet doctor and it has
to decide which mask to accept and which
which ones to reject using the rising
tide algorithm
as the first cluster in its preference
list is the cluster of the blue and
valid doctors it will accept probability
must have from the violet doctor
since the blue doctor did not propose
any mass it is okay to accept an unequal
amount of mass
since there is only half unallocated
mass left it will accept only half
probability mass from the green doctor
therefore the white hospital rejects
half of the probability mass from the
grain doctor
as a result this mass becomes free and
the green doctor will never propose to
the white hospital again
in the next round the green doctor
proposes to the yellow hospital
since it is the first in the list
excluding the white hospital
the blue and violet doctors does not
propose since they do not have frema's
the yellow hospital must now decide
whether to accept the mass it already
accepted all the new proposed mass using
the rising tide algorithm
the first cluster in its preference list
contains the green doctor so the yellow
hospital accept all the probability mass
proposed by them which is half
the next cluster contains the blue and
violet doctors who each proposed half
probability mass with only half of
unallocated probability months left the
yellow hospital will accept a quarter
from each of them and reject the quarter
from each of them
the rejected mass becomes free again
however since they were already rejected
by the yellow hospital their preference
lists remain unchanged
they will propose to the next hospital
in their list
which is the green hospital for the blue
doctor and the white hospital for the
violent doctor
but notice these are exactly the same
proposals as two rounds ago but with
half the free mass
therefore the algorithm will never
terminate however it will converge since
the amount of free mass keeps getting
smaller we stop when the free mass drops
below some threshold and this is what
makes the output of the algorithm
approximately fair and stable
next i will present a proof sketch for
the correctness of the algorithm
in order to prove stability we must
prove that in any matching in the
support of their location there are no
blocking pairs
doctors can only be part of a blocking
pair with hospitals that rejected them
let's say there is such a doctor in a
blocking pair
then the hospital in the blocking pair
prefers this doctor over some doctor in
the support of its allocation
according to the rising tide algorithm
we assumed that the hospital would fill
their location by the order of its
preferences
as well the hospital can always choose
the allocation from the previous round
thus the allocation can only improve
this implies that the hospital will
always weekly prefer
any doctor in its allocation to the
rejected doctor
so no blocking pills are possible
in order to prove fairness we need to
show that the allocation is envy free
within each cluster
that is that each doctor prefers its own
allocation to that of every other doctor
within the cluster
let's fix two doctors d1 and d2 from the
same cluster to have envy freeness in
terms of stochastic domination we have
to make sure that for every k d1 is
assigned with its top k hospitals with
at least the same probability
as d2
in the rising tide algorithm we said
that if d1 and d2 propose to the same
hospital h in some round
h will accept more mass from v2 then
from d1
only if d2 proposed exactly the amount
that was accepted by h
we allow that because we assume that
this means that the rest of the one's
mass is assigned to hospitals that d1
prefers over age
and then they want the location would
stochastically dominate the two's
allocation
however
what if it is not the case what if d1
got rejected by h in an earlier round
and the end it is assigned with
hospitals it prefers less than h
which means that the one and this d2
we show that this can never happen
if in some round d1 got rejected by h
then in any later round no doctor from
d1s cluster would be assigned with
higher probability mass form h
since each probability mass can be
rejected only once the algorithm
converges but not necessarily stops
we stop when the total amount amount of
free mass drops below some threshold
in this work we showed that under the
assumption of a photometric
and fair hospital preferences there is
always a fair and stable solution and it
can be found using our algorithm
but what if we removed one of the
assumptions
we show that in that case no algorithm
in the style of the gail sharply
algorithm guarantees both fairness and
stability
we show this by defining a general
algorithm class that contains algorithms
of this type
here i present the subclass where the
doctors are proposing but in the paper
we also show the corresponding class
where the hospitals are proposing
all the algorithms in the class proceed
in grounds
in each round the doctors propose the
full probability mass to the hospitals
we assumed that the doctors must propose
by the order of their preferences
after the proposals the hospitals can
choose which ones to accept and which
ones must to reject
we assumed that after the mass was
rejected it cannot be proposed again to
the same hospital
the algorithm stops if there is no free
mass or if the free mass is very small
as we did in our propose and project
algorithm
these algorithms are local in the sense
that each participant has to be aware
only to its own preference and act upon
it
there is no central decision maker
we showed that for this class of local
algorithms there is no algorithm that
guarantees both fairness and stability
the full proof of this result is in the
paper
to conclude we showed that under the
assumption of fair hospital preferences
in the photometric there is always a
fair and stable solution
also we showed an algorithm that finds
it
in all the other cases we showed
barriers in finding such an algorithm
inclining that if such an algorithm
exits it will require a different
approach
we are still left with some open
questions
such as are fairness and stability
compatible in the general case is there
an efficient algorithm to find such a
matching or say whether it exists or not
there are also questions about the
properties of the algorithm we found
whether it is incentive compatible or
optimal to one of the sets
we leave these questions open for future
research
that's it thank you for listening